hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game uh this one from 1921 it
was played in Hogan it's a game between
former world champion maxiva and Akiba
Rubinstein for those of you who know
your chess history and I imagine most of
you do uh the two names that don't
really come as a surprise like I said
max sugar was a a world champion from
1935 from to 1937 not all that long he
took it from Alexander aleckin and then
okay I'll let him just stopped smoking
and drinking and then he took it away
from Max survey and then he held it
until the day he died and then fide was
left without a world champion very
abruptly and they thought of this great
idea uh let's organize a candidates
tournament and that's how candidate
tournaments came into existence so very
nicely done by fide but getting back to
this game his opponent in this game is
none other than the great Akiba
Rubenstein he is also known to be one of
those players uh who well uh best
players of the era and never to become
world champion uh he was definitely a
Slayer of world champions he had a great
score against
um uh pretty much everyone he played he
against Lasker he uh okay he I think
Lasker had a plus one on him against
capablanca they they drew like eight
games uh Rubenstein won one Kappa Blanca
1-1 uh against the legend he didn't have
a great score he had like four wins the
eight wins ayahan won eight games eight
games against Rubenstein but it is said
that Rubenstein played his best chess up
until at the beginning of World War One
uh uh maybe some 1913 1914 and after
World War one uh his uh chess and the
mental health somewhat deteriorated so
he couldn't perform
quite uh on that level before because
before World War one uh he played a lake
in four times okay one was a
consultation game it was um and a friend
I guess against Rubenstein and a friend
and that game was won by and his
teammate but the three other games that
they played Rubenstein won all three and
only after World War One when they
started playing each other uh they can
won all the other uh games that we
discussed uh and here we have a game
against you they're getting back to that
just wanted to introduce the players a
little bit uh let's check it out it's
quite a beautiful game and uh really
really a wild one and uh a lot of cool
pause the video moments for you guys to
solve so let's check it out with the
white pieces opened with Pawn to E4
Rubenstein replies with C5 he goes for
the Sicilian Defense sorry about that
uh we have Knight to F3 uh Knight the F6
are going for the names of each
variation of the Sicilian and now Pawn
to E5 we have Knights to D5 and now Pawn
to D4 so something that you would see
even uh in modern chess C captures on
the four Queen captures and now Pawn to
E6 and now uh there are a couple of
moves that come to mind here and
nowadays okay you know that you're gonna
play Bishop the C4 or A3 or maybe even
Bishop to D3 but if it tries the very
ambitious Pawn to C4 and this uh is a a
a little bit too much to ask for because
here Rubenstein goes Knight to the C6 he
attacks the queen queen back to D1 and
not Knight back to E7 so okay it seems
like you've pushed the Knight back into
a corner but the Knight is really being
re-maneuvered to G6 and then you will
have a whole lot of pressure on that
advanced E5 Pawn so maybe you've
Advanced a bit too far with Bishop to D2
moves you can consider here are some
like Knight C3 Bishop D3 Bishop D2
so uh in some order you have to play
them but Rubenstein sorry Uber knows
that the E5 Pawn will come under attack
with moves like an ig6 and queen to C7
and he wants to be ready to play Bishop
to C3 to help defend it so Knights the
G6 attacking the pawn with Queen E2
adding a Defender we have Queen to C7
adding a third attacker and the bishop
to C3 adding a third Defender we have
Pawn to B6 preparing to feed Kettle or
maybe go even Bishop to A6 uh and now uh
the the problem is let's say you play
something like Knight to B2 I'm not beta
D do you want to develop Bishop to B4 is
incredibly annoying because uh here
rubenstra would be threatening to just
mess up your Pawn structure and if you
capture it's a bishop captures Knight
captures there's Knight to C2 check the
thread you can't Castle because of
Knight captures on A2 just a very very
uh silly position to already have with
white and it's like move 10 if Knight D4
guarding C2 then you no longer control
uh the E5 Pawn uh so pretty bad but okay
after B6 with Pawn to H4 makes sense and
of the Knight is on G6 you want to kick
it away with H5 now comes Pawn to D6
very nicely done now with H5 we can just
capture an E5 so e captures on D6 Bishop
captures uh and now what's up with
Bishop captures and G7 is that even a
possibility
uh it is but you have to be very very
precisely in calculating everything
because after Bishop captures on G7 look
at this Knight to F4 now you have to
play Queen to D2 and now Rook to G8 okay
the bishop is hanging and uh here okay
probably you stop calculating because
you see okay the bishop moves then the
G2 Pawn Falls and my position just falls
apart you actually can play this but you
have to find Knight the C3 now the idea
is as the bush fund D6 is already
attacked Knight the B5 would be a
problem for black so here Bishop to A6
and now after black uh sorry after White
Castles again putting pressure on the
bishop here uh Rook to d8 and now what
do you play here Bishop to H6 saying
okay black really doesn't have any good
discoveries Knight captures on G2 and
okay maybe you can play this but it it
doesn't look like much so instead after
Bishop captures on D6 uh we have Knight
beta D2 even though Bishop captures and
G7 the one we discussed is the strongest
move recommended by the engine you can
see how from a a human standpoint it's
not really something to look forward to
so after Knight beat the D2 Knight F4 by
Rubenstein going after the queen and now
uh you have to go back Queen to D1
that's what you have to do but uh didn't
really want to put his Queen on the
starting square but you have to play it
Queen the D1 then you kick away tonight
then you play Bishop G2 then you castle
and that's how you play but okay he
played Queen to E3 and now Bishop to C5
uh asks the question what is happening
with the queen queen E4 only move pretty
much Pawn to F5 and now Queen back the
C2 now that D1 Square doesn't look all
that bad as now you've um uh helped
Rubinstein develop maybe a bit too much
uh we have Castles by Akiba and now
comes Pawn to G3 here you could maybe
castle and give up the F2 Pawn uh in
order to to try and survive but it's
still not a great position we have
castles on opposite sides it's much
easier for black to attack your already
down material and there's really nothing
to go for here pushing on the king side
you have nothing to push with so here G3
attacking the Knight Knight the G6 now
we have H5 Knight G to E5 and again you
can't really castle if you Castle Knight
G4 and again you have big problems here
so uh Uber has to figure out a way out
of this he plays Knight captures on E5
Knight captures on E5 and now Pawn to B4
he wants to kick away the Bishop from
this diagonal and then Castle Queen side
and hopefully survive this game maybe
even go for a nice attack here but
that's easier said than done feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
an Unstoppable idea for Rubenstein uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing why it's
possible and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is the best shop
captures on F2 with check you could also
consider Bishop to B7 but this is a more
precise Bishop captures an F2 check now
you have to capture otherwise you have
to admit that you did not consider this
so King captures an F2 and not Knights
the G4 check and now the point is you
cannot uh defend the G3 Pawn if you go
King to G2 then well I mean Bishop B7
Knight to E3 check wins the queen uh not
possible so instead after this Knight
captures on G4 check we have King the E2
and now again what do you play uh the
the way to continue this and here
Rubenstein messes up is Bishop to B7
this is what you have to play Rubenstein
did not go for this he rushed it a
little bit but after Bishop to B7
there's just uh no move white can play
you can move the Rook as The Rook here
is hanging Rook to G1 and now Pawn to F4
threatening to open a BF file or even F3
check is coming so after captures and
captures there's not much for white to
do here if King to D1 Queen E3 and The
Rook cannot be saved but after King to
E2 Rubinstein hurried with Queen
captures on G3 I mean it it just looks
too good not to play it but now there
actually is a way for uh Max to save
this position but it's incredibly
difficult to Define however you guys are
always up to the task feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only move
that not only saves the game for white
but also gives white a better position
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
one of the more difficult tasks I've
tasked you with in a while and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course Queen to D3 that's the
way to do it
um they did not find it and uh well the
the rest of the game uh will follow but
we're gonna discuss this line the point
is now you are uh offering a queen trade
and black already sacrificed a piece so
he can't trade attackers so let's say
queen F2 check King to D1 and now Bishop
to the B Bishop to B7 it seems like uh
you know you're still uh coming through
but Rook to H3 and the black has nothing
if roket to d8 seems like you are
unstoppable here just Queen E2 and
there's nothing there's really nothing
you can play like whatever you play
you're just gonna be worse you're
already down a piece and white survived
the attack but uh he didn't spot it
after Queen captures on G3 Bishop the D4
was played and now uh well uh the that
that is a problem for uh for for Max
with Bishop to B7 attacking The Rook
here Rook to H3 attacks the queen and
now Queen to D6 now the bishop on D4 is
a target otherwise Queen D6 would not
come with Tempo Queen to C3 also having
some very nice pressure against that G7
pawn and pawn to E5 now we have Bishop
to G1 look at this Mighty Bishop pair
and now Pawn to F4 yeah and here you
could try running away King to D1 let's
say then you see Knight the E3 check of
course you have to you can't really even
trade here this opens up the f file for
the other Rook so you have to move the
the king back let's say Knight captures
Knight captures and you try to survive
this but the pawns are Marching forward
it would not be easy to at uh to last
long here so instead Pawn to C5 was
played makes sense you played with Tempo
and also you free up this diagonal for
for any incoming checks but now Queen to
H6 now threatening F3 check so King the
E1 and sorry not the D1 King the E1 King
to D1 can also be considered but for
some reason I guess he wanted to avoid
Rook to d8 um maybe I mean the the
position is so open there are many many
reasons why he would choose King to E1
instead of King to D1 but now Pawn to E4
and look at this all of this control uh
black controlling so many squares here
uh it's disgusting to even play this and
here we have rooked the H4 the final uh
move that uh that loses the game for
forever I will just show a line that is
so spectacular uh that is pretty much
the only way for irva to save this game
is Bishop back to D4 the move should
come to mind because once uh Rubenstein
played E4 and he did rush it a little
bit uh he again lost control over the D4
square and it's one of those uh things
that we constantly repeat you know one
of Josh Wayne waitkins
um uh you know the the square that was
left Left Behind the bishop to D4 and
now the problem is let's say E3 you will
play Knight to C4 and after F3 it seems
like all is lost but now you play Knight
to D6 and okay you're attacking the
bishop but that doesn't really matter uh
what matters is that you've blocked off
the D file and you're controlling the E8
Square so you don't have to worry about
anything there and now after E2 yes the
bishop is lost but now you have Queen C4
check King to h8 and knights the F7
check forcing a trade here captures and
captures and after e captures an F1 with
queen king captures uh now there are
many options here but the only good one
for black is Knight to E3 with check you
will of course uh decline this trade
King to F2 and now uh you could continue
with Knight G4 check 93 you could repeat
here or you could try Knight F5 the
defend G7 and attack the bishop here but
now Queen captures an F5 and queen to D2
with check King G3 Queen captures on D4
grabbing back the material and now Rook
to E1 and all of a sudden white is back
in the game it's not there's not really
all that much that try here but it would
be best for example Queen D2 going for
Queen to G2 check can be met with Queen
to E5 it's such a such a complicated
position but uh I mean allowing Queen to
G to check is crazy Queen G2 check think
the H4 your king is actually safe on H4
and I have to clean to have to check
you're gonna play Rook to G3 Queen to HD
check Rook to H3 you don't mind the
trade here but even though you don't
mind again you can only repeat moves
here Queen F2 check Queen H2 check or
you can trade here characters captures
and then play Pawn to F2 and again we
trade down into into a nice draw let's
say Rook to F5 Bishop to G2 and you're
winning the material back Rook captures
an F2 Bishop captures King captures and
knock let's say captures captures and
Rook to C8 uh equal end game not much to
be done about this so that was the way
to save this uh forever if he had found
Bishop to D4 but he plays Rook the H4
and now this is a problem now Rubinstein
plays Queen to G E5 and the queen
believe it or not is much more useful on
the G file than on the H file as now
okay you can't really do anything about
the Rook if you move the Rook now now
Ponte E3 is deadly because after Knight
the C4 you will play Rook 8 to E8 and
after Knight to D6 you will simply
ignore this you're gonna play Knight to
the E5 now you have a very nice control
Knight to F3 check also a problem and if
Bishop to H2 uh sort of uh getting that
Bishop also out of the way that was
under attack uh Bishop to G2 now attacks
the rook and the bishop here and let's
say Knight captures an E8 Bishop
captures an H3 Bishop captures and will
capture 78 White will not be able to
survive this the bishop pair isn't
really doing all that much the king is
still only one the pawns will March
forward and that is it so instead after
Queen G5 Queen the H3 was attempted by
by other and now comes Knight to E3 uh
forcing a trade here again Queen
captures and G1 is the is the threat but
many the other threats in the position
like Knight to C2 check so Bishop
captures an E3 F captures on E3 and now
Bishop to C4 with check King to h8 and
now Knight to F1 you have to do
something the Knight is hanging so
Knight to F1 but now there are many cool
ways to finish the game uh Rubenstein
just plays the the most natural one
Queen to F6 and it was in this position
unmoved uh 33 that Max resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
Queen to have to check uh too big a
thread and also just Queen characters on
A1 uh too big a threat uh point is if if
you move the Rook uh then of course just
Queen to F2 with checking the one you
don't have Checkmate because the Knight
is covering that but I mean rotate to d8
to check and that's it now you have the
block with uh
uh you can give up some pieces here like
the queen like the bishop and then once
you give up the Knight it will be
checkmate uh so yeah after Queen to F6
over resigned and a spectacular victory
for akibar Rubinstein uh in This
brilliant brilliant game so it's a shame
that he didn't get the the play manual
Oscar for the title they should they
should have had their match in 1914 but
then uh due to the outbreak of the world
war one uh it was postponed and never to
be uh resumed uh so uh uh you know a
pretty big loss for the Chess World as
Rubenstein was really a monster
um up until 1914. uh but yeah what are
you gonna do uh we are left with his
games to enjoy and okay this was not the
most precise game but it was a most
complicated one and he came uh out on
top against a future world champion and
as you guys I imagine are always
interested these are the standings of um
uh this 1921 uh Hawk tournament so let's
check out how everyone did uh the
tournament was a perfect tournament for
Alexandra yekin who won it without
losing a single game eight out of nine
seven wins and two draws
uh second place with seven out of nine
and Akiba Rubinstein with six and a half
uh he got third place here which is very
nice uh other contenders
finishing second to last and Fred Yates
uh finishing in last place uh so yeah
very nice game I hope you guys enjoyed
it Akiba Rubenstein always deadly with
the black pieces if you haven't seen
rubenstein's Immortal game it is uh
there's uh there are maybe a few games
that are as spectacular as Ruby as
rubenstein's Immortal against rot Levy
uh so if you haven't seen it do check it
out I will put a link to it in the
description below I think I made two
videos on that like a really old one
some six years ago and then like uh
improved version uh so I will put both
links so you know choose whichever one
you you prefer that's the game and a
little bit of history behind the game
hope you enjoyed that as well I would
like to thank Simon Johnson a ravishing
reptiles YouTube Francisco masoko
randomfile.net and the Jimbo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World tomorrow the
Tata still starts so uh we are in uh for
a treat uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day